A devastating discovery has been made in
Canada: the remains of 215 children have
been found buried at the site of a former
boarding school for indigenous students.
The school in British Columbia was part of a
nationwide scheme that took in First Nations
children, in an effort to assimilate them into
Canadian society. Investigations have shown there
was widespread abuse. These latest findings are
once again opening a wound that has yet to heal.
Row upon row of children's shoes – each
pair marking a lost son or daughter.
In Vancouver, people gathered to mourn the
215 children whose remains were found at
a former Indigenous residential
school, with ground-penetrating
radar confirming the grim discovery.
"It was shocking at every single level.
And you know right now you know our community
is grieving. We all had to take time to
absorb what we were told, what we'd seen. And, you
know, we're still grappling through the effects."
Founded in 1890, the Kamloops school was one of
Canada's state-run Indigenous residential schools.
After being forcibly separated from their parents,
children were made to convert to Christianity
and banned from speaking their native languages.
Physical and sexual abuse by headmasters and
teachers was common -- a 2015 report found that
over 3,200 children had died from maltreatment and
neglect in what it called a "cultural genocide."
The Kamloops school closed in 1978 – but rumors
persisted that the deaths of many children had
been covered up. Canada's politicians – including
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau – said
they were heartbroken by the news.
"There's nothing more painful
in life than losing a child.
My heart breaks today thinking of all the loving
parents who never saw their children return home."
The Tk'emlups te Secwepemc tribe says it
is working with the coroner and museums
to try to shed light on the grim discovery
– and find records of the children's deaths.